let us now put to use our understanding
of the coin tossing model and The
Associated binomial probabilities we
will solve the following problem we have
a coin which is tossed 10 times and we
are told that exactly three out of the
ten tosses resulted in heads given this
information we would like to calculate
the probability that the first 2 tosses
were heads this is a question of
calculating a conditional probability of
one event given another the conditional
probability of event a namely that the
first 2 tosses were heads
given that another event B has occurred
namely that we had exactly 3 hands out
of the 10 tosses however before we can
start working towards the solution to
this problem we need to specify a
probability model that we will be
working with we need to be explicit
about our assumptions to this effect
let us introduce the following
assumptions we will assume that the
different coin tosses are independent in
the statistical sense in addition we
will assume that each coin toss has a
fixed probability P the same for each
toss that a particular toss results in
hands these are the exact same
assumptions that we made earlier when we
derived the binomial probabilities and
in particular we have the following
formula that if we have n tosses the
probability that we obtain exactly K
heads is given by this expression so now
we have a model in place and also the
tools that we can use to analyze this
particular model let us start working
towards a solution actually we will
develop two different solutions and
compare them at the end
the first approach which is the safest
one is the following since we want to
calculate the conditional probability
let us just start with the definition of
conditional probabilities the
conditional probability of an event
given another event is the probability
that both events happen divided by the
probability of the conditioning event
now let us specialize to the particular
example that we're trying to solve so in
the numerator we are talking about the
probability that event a happens and
event B happens what does that mean
this means that event a happens that is
the first two tosses resulted in heads
which I'm going to denote symbolically
this way but in addition to that event B
happens and event B requires that there
is a total of three heads which means
that we had one more head in the
remaining tosses so we have one head in
tosses three all the way to 10
as for the denominator let's keep it the
way it is for now so let's continue with
the numerator we're talking about the
probability of two events happening that
the first 2 tosses were heads and that
in toss is 3 up to 10 we had exactly one
head here comes the independence
assumption because the different tosses
are independent whatever happens in the
first two tosses is independent from
whatever happened in tosses 3 up to 10
so the probability of these two events
happening is the product of their
individual probabilities so we first
have the probability that the first 2
tosses were heads which is P squared and
we need to multiply it with the
probability that there was exactly one
head in the tosses numbered from 3 up to
10 these are 8 tosses the probability of
one head in 8 tosses is given by the
binomial formula with k equal to 1 and n
equal to 8 so this expression this part
becomes 8 choose 1 P to the first power
times 1 minus P to the 7th power so this
is the numerator the denominator is
easier to find this is the probability
that we had three heads in 10 tosses so
we just use this formula the probability
of 3 heads is given by 10 tosses choose
3 P to the third times 1 minus P to the
7th power and here we notice that terms
in the numerator and denominator cancel
out and we obtain 8 choose 1 divided by
10 choose 3 and to simplify things just
a little
or what is 8 choose one this is the
number of ways that we can choose one
item out of 8 items and this is just 8
we can choose any one of those items
understand of them and let's leave the
denominator the way it is so this is the
answer to this to the question that we
had and now let us work towards
developing a second approach towards
this particular answer in our second
approach we start first by looking at
the sample space and understanding what
conditioning is all about in our model
we have a sample space as usual
we can denote it by Omega and the sample
space contains a bunch of possible
outcomes a typical outcome is going to
be a sequence of length 10 the sequence
of heads or tails and it's a sequence
that has length 10 we want to calculate
conditional probabilities and this
places us in a conditional universe we
have the conditioning event B which is
some set and conditional probabilities
are probabilities defined inside sum
inside this sub in this set B and define
the probabilities the conditional
probabilities of the different outcomes
what are the elements of the set B a
typical element of the set B is a
sequence which is a game of length 10
but has exactly three heads so these are
the three head sequences
now since we're conditioning on event B
we can just work with conditional
probabilities so let us find the
conditional probability law recall that
any three head sequence has the same
probability of occurring in the original
unconditional probability model namely
as we discussed earlier any particular
three head sequence has a probability
equal to this expression so three head
sequences are all equally likely this
means that the unconditional
probabilities of all the elements of B
are the same when we construct
conditional probabilities given an event
B what happens is that the ratio or the
relative proportions of the
probabilities remain the same so
conditional probabilities are
proportional to unconditional
probabilities these elements of B were
equally likely in the original model
therefore they remain equally likely in
the conditional model as well what this
means is that the conditional
probability law on the set B is uniform
given that B occurred all the possible
outcomes now have the same probability
since we have a uniform probability law
this means that we can now answer
probability questions by just counting
we're interested in the probability of a
certain event a given that B occurred
now given that B occurred this part of a
cannot happen so we're interested in the
probability of outcomes that belong in
this shaded region those outcomes that
belong within the set B to find the
probability of this shaded region
occurring we just need to count how many
outcomes belong to the shaded region and
divide them by the number of outcomes
that belong to the set B that is we work
inside this condition
universe all the elements in this
conditional universe are equally likely
and therefore we calculate probabilities
by Counting
so the desired probability is going to
be the number of elements in the shaded
region which is the intersection of a
with B divided by the number of elements
that belong to the set B how many
elements are there in the intersection
of a and B these are the outcomes or
sequences of length 10 in which the
first two tosses were heads no choice
here and there is one more head that
additional head can appear in one out of
eight possible places so there's eight
possible sequences that have the desired
property how many elements are there in
the set B how many three had sequences
are there well the number of three had
sequences is the same as the number of
ways that we can choose three three
elements out of set of cardinality 10
and this is 10 choose 3 as we also
discussed earlier so this is the same
answer as we derived before with our
first approach so both approaches of
course give the same solution this
second approach is a little easier
because we never had to involve any
piece in our calculation we got to the
answer directly the reason that this
approach worked was that the conditional
universe the event B had a uniform
probability law on it